gas prices are absolutely exploding
across the united states and a lot of
people are wondering every time they go
to the pump what the hell is going on
well here's exactly why you're seeing
gasoline prices go up so much we take a
look yesterday gasoline prices
officially went up 12
in the last week and what we are seeing
is the current average is over four
dollars for a regular gallon of gasoline
if we then go ahead and look 12 of
americans are actually paying an average
of
and 34 cents per gallon this is insanity
compared to historical prices so what
exactly is going on well if we take a
look here what we can see is that the
price of oil has been exploding over the
last couple of months we can see that on
november 1st it was 68 on the 1st of
december 77 by january 89 by february 97
and now it is about 130
that is almost double where it was to
start november and so ultimately when we
watch oil exploding upwards it naturally
trickles through the gasoline price that
you'll pay at the pump but why is the
price of oil exploding well if we go
ahead and we take a look you can see
that all of this on the far right here
has occurred in 2022 it's just up and to
the right that explosion in price is
because there is geopolitical
uncertainty and chaos unfolding we know
that russia has invaded ukraine and we
know that russia is the third largest
oil producer in the world they produce
17
of all natural gas in the world as well
but if you look at the top 10 largest
oil producers the united states is one
with 18.6 million barrels per day and
russia's number three at 10.5 million
barrels per day they make up about 11
percent of the total world's share of
oil production but then if we go and we
take a look at who consumes the most oil
you can see that the united states is
number one there as well they may
produce 18 million barrels but they
consume 20 million barrels per day
meaning that the united states is a net
importer of oil we are not energy
independent we rely on oil from other
places around the world however russia
they're a net exporter they produce more
oil than they actually go ahead and
consume and so the united states
we don't have enough energy production
here within our borders and we are
reliant on oil from external sources
that oil price is exploding upwards
because of the reliance on russian oil
for europeans for people in north
america and others around the world and
as the price of oil explodes upwards
you'll continue to pay more at the pump
but it's not just russia either
inflation has been ravaging the united
states we now have inflation over seven
percent in the u.s and so naturally that
trickles through to goods that you
consume like gasoline as well and so
whether it's supply chains geopolitical
instability or it's just pure inflation
the price of gasoline is going to
continue to move upwards until these
problems get solved hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time